Most Android apps won't
live alone on the device.
You'll probably want to talk
to your app at some point.
And to do that you'll need a server.
Now, I'm not going to walk you
through building a server.
There are plenty of resources
out there for that.
Instead, I'm going to show you how
to communicate with your server.
So let's focus on how to get data
from your server to your app.
The easy way,
which you're already familiar with,
is known as polling the server.
This is when your app
calls up the server,
just to see if anything has changed.
With a repeating alarm, the app does
this after a specified amount of time.
But, with a sync adapter, it'll do
it whenever the radio is turned on,
after some time has already passed.
Sorry, let me just, there.
Sorry.
So, by waiting for the radio to be
activated by something else, we can
spare a bit of battery life, but that
requires a flexible timing schedule.
So you need to determine what
your priorities are when choosing
a polling method.
For example, in Sunshine, we poll
the weather servers every three hours,
give or take,
to keep the weather data up to date.
An alternative to polling
would be pushing.
With this method, the server is
responsible for the messaging and
will inform your app when
new data is available.
Your app doesn't need to regularly
check in with the server.
Just, okay.
Where was I?
Oh yeah, pushing.
Oh, pushing.
What a good idea.
Okay.
So pushing can happen in two ways.
Either the server can send a small
message called a tickle, which says
something has changed and asks the app
to sync at its earliest convenience.
Or, the server can just send the updated
data directly to the app and
cut out the middleman.